c'est un univers à part où il faut
savoir observer la nature pour mios
défricher les lois du marché
en haute-saône pendant des décennies une
aristocratie ouvrière a régné sur les
feuillus celle des ébénistes des
fabricants de meubles
[Musique]
et puis peu à peu la société a changé et
le géant de la forêt est arrivé les
petits poucets de l'ameublement ont
presque tous disparu mais certains
résistent encore dans le village d'enjeu
ce jour-là on installait une cuisine
entièrement fabriquée à quelques
kilomètres d'ici
et avec du vrai bois de la région pour
certains un simple chantier pour
d'autres une cérémonie l'a produite et
pink fabriqué artisanalement un produit
noble c'est vivant le bois que les
nouveaux produits sépare vivent le
stratifié et là qu'est tout ça c'est
beau c'est des couleurs
l'immeuble de la cuisine viennent de ce
magasin plutôt spacieux
il appartient à la famille des chambres
noires et il faut le reconnaître c'est
l'une des dernières entreprises
artisanales en franche comté à fabriquer
autant de meubles à la demande
une table comme ça avec les annonces qui
sont à l'intérieur c'est vrai que ça
peut être fait que chez un artisan cd
allonge massive qui sont inclus dans la
table avec des systèmes de roulette sous
l'équipe une filière courte qui aurait
pu disparaître avec la mondialisation
mais les deschamps benoît comme d'autres
se sont accrochés et les clients suivi
soit fabriqué aussi la part des gens
d'ici il fait dé proximité et aussi que
s'il ya un problème
après les sur place mais bon c'est mieux
c'est du ca fait travailler le secteur
la filière bois dans chacun des acteurs
surtout qui a fallu se moderniser c'est
vrai qu'au départ c'était de la
fabrication bois rustique et dès qu'il a
fallu faire ce type de fabrication plus
moderne avec avec des ralentisseurs avec
des matériaux différents
pour certains c'était très compliqué
nous on a réussi à le faire mais ça a
été vraiment du travail a fallu que nos
employés se se mettre à une autre un
autre système de fabrication
[Musique]
ici on rappelle en permanence aux
visiteurs que les meubles sont bien
fabriqué dans l'atelier qui se trouve
tout à côté
chaque jour une équipe d'ébéniste
conçoit et assemble des meubles et pour
y parvenir
c'est toute une filière qui se
mobilisent
je ne tenais